let's be honest sometimes it's just fun
to be left hanging so it's doctor who
lists time again and this time I'm going
to count down what I think are the top
10 cliff hangers in New Era Doctor Who
now as usually happens with my list I
got to clarify a few things before I get
started now as I said I'm only doing new
whoo meaning starting with the
Christopher Eccleston the Ninth Doctor
going forward from there I'm not doing
classic era because while I am working
towards filling in the gaps of my
classic era knowledge I still don't have
enough to really be able to integrate
that into these lists yet next I need to
clarify precisely what I mean by a cliff
hanger a cliff hanger isn't just a
matter of the story's not done we know
there's more the characters are being
left in a particularly perilous
situation where the way they are going
to get out of it is not clear and I also
want to specify some things that I'm not
going to count as cliff hangers the end
of the doctor Falls and the name of the
doctor those are not cliff hangers what
they were is they were completed stories
that dangled a clear thing that the next
story is going to be but there's nothing
perilous about the situation that they
are immediately left in so it's less of
a dangling at the edge of a cliff and
stopping the story there which is where
the term comes from from serialized
storytelling it's less of that and more
like the hero pulled himself up onto the
cliff he's now safe and looking out at a
castle that we know he's going to go to
in the next adventure I'm intrigued I
want to see what happens it's not a
cliff and but one last thing I want to
be clear about is this list and the
things on it I'm talking about the
cliffhanger only the quality of the
episode that the cliffhanger is at the
end of is not being taken to account how
well or poorly the cliffhanger is
resolved in the following episode is not
taken into account only the cliffhanger
itself
number 10 the stolen earth now I know in
the years since the fake-out
regeneration has become honestly a bit
of a cliche they've used it too much but
when this happened
that was a big deal anybody who was
really excessively closely following the
produc
and knew that David Tennant had more
episodes he was going to appear in but
at the moment that it happened he goes
into a regeneration what is going to
happen are we going to lose him if we're
not going to lose him how is he going to
get out of this that is a heck of a
moment to end an episode on back when
they did it for the first time as I said
it sadly become overplayed since then
but back when we got it right here in
series 4 ooh that was that was a tense
moment to leave us on number 9 dark
water I kind of wanted to put dark water
higher than this but if I'm honest I
have to take the value of the
cliffhanger and the Missi reveal while
cool and I did enjoy is kind of a
secondary aspect of the cliffhanger it
reveals who Missy is and why we should
be taking her really seriously but we
kind of already knew she was bad news so
that's just more of an easter egg
so it's placement on this list has more
to do with Cybermen just took over earth
so first of all that's a heck of a
situation to be in and we know that
there's a massive number of them because
the dead are now Cybermen how do we get
out of this and plus bonus great visual
reference to earlier Cybermen invasion
of Earth story so this is just it's a
great nostalgic trip and if I'm really
tense ending for that episode number
eight Heaven Sent
now this one bends the guidelines that I
set ever so slightly because the doctor
himself had just got out of peril and
he's not in immediate danger at this
point but when he steps out of that
confession dial and we realize he's on
Gallifrey there is definitely a palpable
sense of tension and terror but more
about what is he going to do as opposed
to what's going to happen to him so it's
a little bit of an inverse as far as
cliffhangers go but that was a heck of a
moment to end on because I mean we
hadn't seen Gallifrey for a while at
this point and to realize that they had
just put him through this ha it makes it
seem like this is not a place that we
necessarily want to be back to in terms
of it being safe for the doctor but he's
now in out you now on I care what is he
gonna do to this place number 7 the
Pandorica opens oh there's so much about
this cliff
okay first of all we've got the entire
just cadre of villains who have all
teamed up to face the doctor we've got
Daleks we've got Cybermen Sontarans just
random like background villains
basically anything to tell if a costume
four shows up here so you've got all
these villains the doctor in the box and
the doors closing as the universe is
exploding everywhere you want to talk
about a situation that you don't know
how you're going to get out of because
not only is the hero being trapped in
something that you don't know how he can
escape but you watch as the thing that
you would think he needs to prevent
happens I mean it happens he's not in
time to stop it universe defended whoa
and man did it leave us on pins and
needles waiting to see how that little
ones gonna play out number six the
impossible planet food closing in and
this pit that so much sort of mystery
and dread had surrounded just opening
and we have no idea what's in there we
don't know what's going to come out we
don't know what is waiting below that we
have no idea this was kind of
interesting because while there is sort
of an immediate sense of danger from the
closing in on some members of the cast
the doctor himself isn't there he's in
front of the pit and we don't see
anything coming out of the pit so there
isn't that immediate sense of exactly
what the threat is that you usually get
with the cliffhanger usually with a
cliffhanger we know exactly what the
danger is it's just a question of how
does the hero get out of it in this case
we actually didn't even know and that
was part of what made it so tense like
this thing that seems to be just this
ancient horrible evil like what is it we
don't know but whatever it is it's free
that is a terrific balance of both a
terrifying situation but maintaining a
certain air of mystery beyond just a
question of how did the heroes get out
of this we don't even know yet what
they're facing and that in a way just
makes it tenser number five army of
ghosts this this cliffhanger just keeps
on coming because first of all we've had
this thing going on where these ghosts
are all over the planet what are they
what are they
but they're Cybermen the Cybermen just
basically invaded the planet the world
over and they won the doctor says that
himself
this isn't an invasion this is a victory
they've already won how do you bring
that up another level you bring in
Daleks on top of that the cult of Skaro
emerging from that sphere I would not
have thought it was possible to up the
oh crap factor that this episode already
had going that is a way to do it
number four world enough and time a bit
more on the melancholy side as far as
cliffhangers tend to go not so much
ratcheting up of deliberate physical
danger but could we just lost bill bill
is now a Cyberman and we've had the
reveal of the master he was there the
whole time
it makes your mind just race crap what
else has he laid the groundwork for what
else has he set up that the doctor is
going to have to deal with on top of the
fact that he just lost his friend to one
of the most horrifying things that can
happen to a character in the world of
Doctor Who and this episode had made a
point of reemphasize
for fiying becoming a Cyberman is so
like I said if not quite it's a little
bit of a different quality cliffhanger
in terms of not necessarily being like
oh my god our heroes about to die but it
definitely has the whole crap how do we
get out of this how do we fix it please
please doctor fix this that is a
terrific overriding sinking feeling that
we get from this ending and having the
realization that an older version the
master that we know is not segment we
cannot trust as opposed to Missy who
seems to have been softening that just
is one more layer of we are screwed on
top of this wonderfully tragic moment
number three bad wolf
this is another one a little bit
different and a little bit atypical
because while Rose is certainly in
immediate danger the doctor himself is
not and actually the note that is the
episode ends on is almost a little bit
more I want to say uplifting but it's
certainly more defined
this is not the doctor backed into a
corner frantically trying to figure out
what to go on this is him staring down
the Daleks going I'm going to take you
on and I'm going to win so now here come
the Daleks invading and remember this is
series one with Christopher Eccleston so
this was back before the Daleks had
shown up and been defeated so many times
that they kind of lost their teeth this
was the only the same time we've seen
them after the episode Daleks so they
are still legitimately scary at this
point and as much as the doctor may be
talking a big game it's really hard to
figure out how in the heck he even with
the help of these other people at this
satellite could possibly take on an
armada of Daleks when he had so much
trouble dealing with just one earlier
that same series it is a perfect
escalation of what had come before and
it is a terrific note to just leave us
going ah waiting for the conclusion
number two
utopia oh man the return of the master
first just with derek jacobi and that
one turned the camera just the Menace in
his face I loved it and then
regenerating to John Simm and he's just
got so much energy enough energy to
match the doctors and he has the TARDIS
he's leaving them their act of mercy of
these this cannibalistic rage that wants
to eat them he had no way to get back
his work his greatest foe possibly ever
just came roaring back into his life and
now he's trapped at the end of time
itself how do we get out of this it's
just a terrific escalation because
honestly this thing could have ended on
just the reveal of the Masters back and
it still would have been great to do
that and then have the master in the
immediate sense win get his hands on the
TARDIS and leave and leave the doctor's
companions there oh boy talk about
especially for people who are new to who
and didn't know classic Doctor Who yet
emphasizing right off the bat how much
of a problem this guy is because even if
you've never heard of the master the
fact that he shows up David Tennant that
reaction to him and
the TARDIS right off we are so screwed
but it doesn't quite take my number one
because my number one if you weren't
falling you know all of the background
in the leaks and you know stuff that may
or may not have been revealed ahead of
time because I wasn't following that
southern advance as much at this point
in the series so this came as a surprise
to me what had happened and I loved it
and it stand as my favorite cliffhanger
that new who has given us and that is
the end of time part one we've been
dealing with the master and that alone
has been a big enough problem especially
with David Tennant's Tenth Doctor
knowing that he's going to die soon so
he's off his game
the master is back the master is on a
hinged beyond what he normally is making
him even more dangerous than usual and
then there's that voice we hear that
voices we pull back from the master
having copied himself onto every human
being on the planet and it just keeps
pulling back and we hear that voice
Timothy Dalton's voice and then we get
to see him in that full regalia as
Rassilon he's not even named yet we
don't get in here we don't find out that
that's who he's playing until the next
episode but just their commanding in
front of the Timelords chant the other
guy flying from his mouth this is a man
in a moment of absolute triumph that the
Time Lords are coming back and just in
case you thought oh isn't that a good
thing
the fact that he bellows that this marks
the end of time itself no this is not a
good thing we are all doomed
between the delivery of that moment for
me at least because I hadn't been trying
to get ahead of what was going to be
going on the surprise of that moment and
just Timothy dr. shear presence of
Timothy Dalton that for me is the best
cliffhanger that new who has given us
what are your thoughts about
cliffhangers in Doctor Who what is your
favorite even if you want to drop a
classic error a cliffhanger on me I want
to hear about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down on the comment
let's talk
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]